قال رئيس غرفه الطوارئ الخاصه باجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب بمدينه بورسودان هشام
عثمان ان 13 الفا من الرعايه الاجانب تم
اجلائهم من بورسودان بحرا وجوا
في 17 ولايه من 18 ولايه كلها بتعمل على
مدار الساعه كل مؤسساتنا صحيه مستشفياتنا
مراكزنا الصحيه
كل مراكز تقديم الخدمات بتعمل في كل
الولايات دي نحن واحد من الولاده ولايه
البحر الاحمر ما عدا بعض المستشفيات اللي
في المناطق المتاثره الخرطوم وبعض
الولايات اللي فيها المشاكل فبنصحح
المعلومه دي وبنقول النظام الصحي ما زال
بخير والناس قادره
بالمبادرات المجتمعيه الموجوده بالمعروف
بها انسان
كلنا في طاوله واحده في غرفه الطوارئ
بنعمل من اجل راحه القادمين للاجلاء الان
نحن نتكلم عن
13,000 تم اجلاؤهم بحرا وجوا حتى الان
وقال رئيس غرفه الطوارئ الخاصه باجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب في بورتسودان الجزيره ان
عمليات الاجلاء مستمره لكن المدينه تشهد
تدفقات عاليه من طالبي الاجلاء
في كميه من الطائرات العسكريه الان بمطار
بتجلي بعض الرعايه
وبدت برضه تاركوا وبدء في اجلاء يمكن
لجنوب السودان لين جنبنا للغاهره لابو ظبي
لجده عمليات الاجلاء متواصله لكن المدينه
ما زالت تشهد تدفعات عاليه من القادمين
طلبا للاجلال